[Music]
all right are we rolling we are rolling
hey what's going on man I'm Jamar
Malachi neighbors uh and I'm here on
what's the podcast called good for you
on good for you podcast uh this is
Whitney coming shit and um and this is
cool she got a big ass house
um this shit she should definitely host
uh sex parties here
um and invite me to some
and uh yeah oh I got a special out
called Rott Luther King Jr uh is
directed by Andrew thimulus that shit
funny as fuck you should see that shit
it's real good we filmed it in Pan
Pacific Park
um I also got a eight inch dick it is
black veiny and uh yeah I'm a new host
of uh good for you
um I should be the host of The Daily
Show that's what the fuck we not talking
about but we're not gonna bring that
shit up I'm sorry I'm not wearing a
mohawk today I only want to strap that
shit on my fucking head all the damn
time you know I'm saying it's a whole
responsibility you know when Whitney
comes it's gonna drop that only fans you
know that's what the fuck we all waiting
on now I'm not talking about like only
fans I'm like only fans I wish you go
hey Whitney hey girl hey how you doing
um
all right so this is it this is I
believe the exact product let me see the
prime minister of Canada used for that
Halloween costume the prime minister of
Canada yeah was it was damn you know
everybody
I'm like what the fuck is that remember
that when that prime minister went and
blackface what's his name Trudeau Justin
Trudeau oh true that true
remember he went in his black face it
went up to the water line of his uh he
had it on his hands do we look like that
can you pull this up we made the table
white to bounce off so that it would
illuminate thank you just for me yeah
nope you're a sweetheart black people
disappear in the studio his podcast is
black people friendly
if you're black and you come on my
podcast you will show up on screen yeah
no that's sweet that's sweet no color
lines here
um I'm glad we're doing this a little
bit later at night do you prefer do you
kind of prefer later at night at night
yeah doing a podcast is killing me like
during during the day like having to be
like like
I had to do one at uh you know I had to
do it at one o'clock
um over there in New York so that was
like one ten o'clock and I was I don't
wake up until 12 and I'm not Jamar until
three it's like you know what I'm saying
like I'm not Whitney coming until about
9 30 10 p.m you know and it's also like
there's just something so depressing
Like Comics during the day it's like I
don't know there's something that feels
corny to me about trying to be funny
during the day it feels desperate
whereas for some reason at night it
feels like people like I'm doing a
service to society oh God like I like
you ever have a meeting in the morning
you ever have like a like a meeting
where you got to be on it I really try
not to yeah like because yeah you're
kind of like what I do doesn't go pair
great with 10 a.m croissants yeah every
now and then I'm funny in the morning
like every now and then or whatever but
I'm really
I'm really wisdomy in the morning but
don't you think on some level comedians
do you think that we are kind of
nocturnal by nature or do you think that
we come alive at night because we became
comedians or kind of gravitated towards
being comedians because we already came
alive at night
uh the first one yeah yeah like um like
you know like we basically we basically
fucked up our sleep cycle doing this
shit but I was already had that cycle
before I became a comic like do you
think that someone that goes to bed at
10 every night naturally would ever even
it would even cross their mind to be a
stand-up comic nah nah I guess not for
me I kind of found myself being like
what the fuck do I like I couldn't sleep
I was such an insomnia I guess so when I
was like 16 and shit and I would try to
wait like until them girls going wow
infomercials came on and I would have to
wait till like three o'clock in the
morning just to give my little nut off
and so yeah I guess so I guess so that
kind of trained me up to like you were
already sort of thinking in terms of
being an Entertainer and like yeah sure
you can really only do that at night
unless you're gonna be like and like on
the other like
conversely if you're like the Dork that
goes to bed every night at nine because
you're a narcoleptic or something and
then you wake up every morning at five
or you're like I should be a radio DJ
it's just you know what it was the job
of stand up was just fun and then so I'm
like I could do this all night yeah you
know like and then so that helped can
you walk uh uh the our podcast viewers
and listeners through what drink you're
making okay so Pete this because you
came in is this an audio no no it's not
I mean I literally see this
one behind you of Ariel like this is oh
I bet
um okay I have a face for a radio only
no I don't know you got a gray face you
know what I'm saying it's fucking dope
this is the white one I'm not fucking
with the white wine okay well we spent
20 minutes looking for it we did because
I can make what I want to drink but then
you found this um this uh Baron Jaeger
honey liquor that you got from the prime
minister of motherfuck some some some
country and they could probably never
ever go to
like I think it's Germany I just found
out I'm half Jewish are you half Jewish
I thought you was all Jewish
I died when my mom died of December I
just have to which I was like telling
everyone I was like oh we thought you
were full no you look hella Jewish this
is a downgrade of your then why are you
like this like okay so my sister came up
with this drink that I'm about to
introduce okay uh to the people so she
moved in with me and you know she drank
a little bit and
um I was only on Jack Daniels and and
Coke I was one of those guys okay simple
has that always been your drink yeah
yeah yeah yeah do other Liquors do
something to you you aren't proud of it
all gets you fucked up but sometimes
white one I mean not white wine uh uh
light light liquor is um is a little bit
more intense yeah yeah I feel like I can
only drink tequila I don't know if
that's psychological or if that's true
but I feel like whiskey makes me too
honest with people yeah vodka makes me
like need to let people know the
mistakes they're making yeah like I need
to like be like hey you know what you
should do like it makes me give advice
yeah that no one wants yeah I just feel
like tequila is the only time I'm kind
of like not sending texts I don't need
to be sending man well uh anyway my
sister uh she came up with Bailey's and
Jack and Honey Jack so she got some when
they got some shit some bearing egg or
honey liquor that she got from Germany
here's the thing I was raised by
hardcore alcoholics and I kind of so I
think as a result I I became an Al-Anon
I was like the I was like the sober
driver the person that was kind of like
it's like the opposite of an alcoholic
you actually become addicted to
alcoholics instead of alcohol because
you know I'm having to like clean up
their messes and take care of them so I
never like got super Savvy on like
drinks but I have this like bar
downstairs that I want to make cute and
so I'm kind of just getting things with
labels I like and this has a honey
badger and a bear and I just and then
the Baileys you're the face of this
right now the Bailey's vanilla mint do a
commercial right now with this
motherfucker let me see you do it let me
promote this shit because I don't
believe that you are the face of
Bailey's vanilla mint damn wow don't
believe women good to know women it has
nothing to do with women if well if bird
Chrysler did say he was a face to this I
would I would actually believe him
hold on where's my ad hold on I'll show
you it's on my Instagram somewhere we're
gonna find it and I'm gonna show it
drunk
sorry sorry can you say the n-word on on
good for you you can you can say
whatever you want
logical liar I find it okay uh it was
like um uh Bailey's vanilla mint shake
um
I'm trying to think I can't make jokes
because I feel like I'll get it
Bailey's vanilla mint shake it's so good
you'll Cosby yourself
you said that shit
yo no that's a woman with a sense of
humor but here's the thing about
Bailey's is that you're supposed to put
it in coffee I think coffee and with ice
cream and stuff and I don't have any ice
cream so I'm gonna put it with just some
um cold brew a wheel is putting a Honey
Jack in that shit where's my explain to
me honey Jack what it's Jager is that
Jagermeister not that stuff is like a
bad idea it's whiskey it's Jack Daniels
but that's flavor let me can I just
taste it this not that that's not Honey
Jack that is that is a viscous drink
that is a thick that is thick so that's
what she said hey so so hit that shit oh
stop being a mark and do it what's a
mark a Mark what's that mean what does
it work just drink the drink girl
get drunk
okay hold on I don't think you want me
drunk I I remember are you gonna tell me
are you gonna tell me how it is
what you think ha you soft
it's actually
um like the the oh it's actually good I
just
oh that shit is delicious actually it
kind of tastes like Robitussin at first
and then it hits like a Regal up
oh it's like it goes in waves of like
super delicious and then like
Sherwin-Williams paint delicious
you know cyanide it goes back and forth
but that's a journey now try it with the
mint with the vanilla can you hear me
that yeah with your drink yeah
hold on but I want to pour a little bit
I'm doing tea a little bit of coffee and
Bailey's vanilla mint shake
oh excuse me oh don't mind if I do
on St Patrick's Day so I'm inviting you
to get ready with me for some truly
Irish Whitney are you on Tinder this
is
because when I see you like my shirt off
no wait when I see my friends on Raya I
always want to swipe like to be like
haha but then I'm like wait a second
what if what if we take it seriously
what if we actually fall in love can you
imagine have you ever dated a comedian
date it
okay
sleeping with is even worse are you
insane no I've never I never know I've
never ever dated a comedian how many
comedians have you
boinked uh zero
oh okay
how about uh people in the comedy
community
zero
live what about you is that good is fire
or is it let me taste yours hold on and
so let me ask you when you before you go
on stage do you have a drink like will
you do a shopping yeah take a little bit
of the edge off yeah yeah
daddy Gotta Get Loose
you are a soft oh my God no no
I'm disappointed in you
I know everyone thinks I'm some raging
alcoholic drug addict like I'm really a
lightweight I don't think you do any of
that shit personality it's like even
worse man huh so what'd you think about
this it was that's to I want to fight
like someone I want to like call up my
high school bully and like tell them how
successful I am they should they know
they should serve this after three
o'clock at McDonald's now you know what
there is the Shamrock Shake remember
that what McDonald's has something
called a shamrock it's got pistachio in
it or something I don't know McDonald's
has a couple products that are like
annual that'll pop in and out the McRib
and the Shamrock Shake you fuck with
McDonald's I love McDonald's but why
haven't they done a vegan burger not
that I'm like vegan but yeah you want to
put Whitney in McDonald's like put
Whitney and everything put Whitney in
the liquor put windy in McDonald's like
don't whip me McDonald's up it's just
like
I want an option that's maybe not pure
like my dad essentially ended up dying
of antibiotic resistance and so meat
with a lot of antibiotics in it I just
try to like stay away from oh okay
you're healthy yeah ish yeah not today
but yeah yeah why isn't that healthy
this shit because there's liquor that's
not unhealthy fuck up your liver or some
shit it depends on how I think in
moderation I'm fairly healthy for sure
like you know what I can't you know what
I can't get enough of is those little
shots at uh at whole at a Whole Foods uh
I don't know what it'd be like
wheatgrass or something sure the grass
is not you got to know Ginger or like um
you gotta know what you're doing but
you're also like is it true you were
you're an athlete like you're a real
athlete right yeah you were like boxing
for Real uh I only had one amateur fight
but it was still it was I still did it
but I boxed every day like I boxed today
I'm gonna box tomorrow wait so the
amateur fight like how did this come
about do you have to like pursue it and
okay so what happened was in 2020 right
before covet happened I was gonna go out
for the Golden Gloves it's like the big
the big boxing amateur tournament or
whatever I was gonna go out for it and
then so uh that got canceled because
Kobe oh shit so in October uh some
comedians were like hit me up no you
need to have whatever pour that shit out
I'm gonna pour this out all right this
is what I did so I'm like this is what
happens when I
oh that shit don't even look right show
that shit to the camera
oh yeah pour that shit out with him
do you want to just share I don't
understand just finish this podcast
without me a little bit
I'm Whitney Cummins
uh so um let me just promote some things
I'm on this fool
um that's a that's a good that's a good
show
and um I'm on Raya too that's fire I
just got back from New York that's good
hey all right here give me a drink okay
I want to hear this story I actually
have I actually it's very rare I have
someone on the podcasts that I actually
want to hear talk you really love you're
you're so funny so can you please okay
okay you're gonna pour this I'm just
gonna pour this and I'm just gonna do
the Bailey's vanilla mint shake I don't
I don't need all that I have to edit the
roast after this yeah yeah it's gonna be
way funny if you if you fuck it if you
add a little bit of this in that
motherfucker yeah I'm destroying her
brand I left in Donnell's 98 n words
like this shit's hilarious
also by the way did you see your art
yeah I saw that I saw that I saw that
it's like I just get to stare at it all
the time Jamar made this incredible
piece of art we'll put it in um uh in
post so that you'll be able to see it
and it is so like I knew you're a
brilliant stand up like I remember
during covet I was like watching your
stories and you did a video outside of
the Laugh Factory
what was that again I said I watched it
every day you know what because they
have put George Floyd on the uh they put
George Floyd on the what's her name
and I was like how does nigga get his
name on the Marquee for me and I'll say
he didn't stand in these lines with
these bum ass Comics every fucking
Tuesday to get what did he do to earn
this shit much respect to George Floyd
but I'm a better comic than George Floyd
the like the like disgust on your face
like it was just so real like the
frustration of being a comic and doing
it for so long and working so hard is
disrespected much respectfully is
disrespectful it's like George Floyd
over me and then they put his name on
the La Jolla motherfucking Marquis you
can I'll actually show up if I'm on the
market
false advertising he's always gonna
swing by yo
fuck a dead motherfucker got their name
on the shit before I did that's crazy
whatever anyway so it was in the
pandemic and so anyway I couldn't do the
boxing thing because covet happened and
then so you have been training and
training and then I've been training for
like since like 2000 and fucking
10. and then are you training with
someone you're training I was going
there by myself and do my own thing I
just kind of like pick it up or whatever
like you know like and just go because I
have a lot of energy so I gotta like do
something with it besides where I can't
just sit here and write jokes and shit
like that I have to be super active so I
go to the gym and let me ask you
something why
always like for me if I can't crack a
joke or like stop putting shit in I just
put a little coffee in there so that I
don't fall night night okay go ahead you
can't go Ty tie
um but uh for me it's like I I'm the
same I think I'm maybe a little bit even
manic sometimes yeah um and I'll go on
walks I'll walk on treadmill I'll go
running and that's when I kind of am
able to break jokes you know or break a
story or something like I it took me so
long to realize like my creative process
whatever that is I'm not sitting with a
journal in a pen and like a typewriter
like I'm like gotta be moving Seinfeld
is batshit crazy for doing that
much respect we don't know like I don't
I'm not I'm not I don't know I haven't
heard him talk about this process but I
kind of like every time I hear a
comedian talk about the process I'm like
okay they go to the coffee shop and sit
there and write a million jokes oh well
if it's if you're brainstorming Larry
David like I think that's probably oh
I've been sitting alone writing jokes
like I don't know I'd be for me I also
like like when I started Comics like we
would get together and like like like
run jokes with each other and like fuck
around and like you know I think that we
stopped doing that yeah I think we
stopped doing that because I Feel Like
Comics don't really hang out you know
not for public consumption anymore like
there was a time before podcast when you
would just hang out in the hallway and
like shoot the shit but now it's like oh
do not save it this podcast yeah yeah
like there's none of that yeah but so so
were you already doing stand up when you
started boxing and when you were boxing
do you did you find there was an
improvement in your like performance as
a stand-up yeah hell yeah because the
game I mean I already had confidence but
it gave me like more it gave me like
some it gave me like some uh you know
like it gave me like boxing like gave me
that like some
you know some
uh you know what I mean I do I do like
it gave me like it gave me like like
some sort of like extra level of
confidence or whatever basically I my um
uh ex has a boxing gym and uh it's wild
card West the the west side on the vine
uh there's that one's on mine and then
there's one Wild Card West that's
history off Olympic Peter Berg and
actually Gary shanling they had it
together okay and they still like Canelo
did a camp there like you know and I
went and I trained I had broken my
shoulder so I always wanted to like
learn how to box not that I'd be great
at it or anything but just like
psychologically you know it had been
recommended to me by so many friends of
Mines that were that were athletes
because they were like because I have
trouble being in the present I mean yeah
I'm either in the past you know
self-flagellating arm in the future
future fucking worrying right yeah like
boxing exercises the muscle of you
cannot be a second behind her so you
have to be in the present moment yeah
and it's a way to like build that up in
your brain and then when I started doing
it I was like this is the best way to
practice stand up yeah is because it's
boxing same thing I literally one two
punch set up punch be right there you
can't worry about the thing that just
happened or you're gonna get punched in
the face yeah yep but you could even
break it down to like you could even
break it down to like jokes or whatever
jokes are like certain punches like like
they're like light jokes I'm like okay
that's a jab okay he's on the job yeah
okay Tony jab oh oh that combination of
of you know like saying how it's like
yeah that joke might not be like the
Haymaker but you're building up it was
the setup to oh shit and you don't want
to get them too familiar uh or you don't
want to get too monotonous because
they're gonna you know start to
anticipate what you're gonna do you know
so it's like if you've done it then you
want to go like like it was like blew my
mind and then something else that really
helped me did you Spar anybody no oh
okay no I just do that I feel like yeah
fuck some shit up yeah I just do that
like 2 am
yeah with men mostly you fought a man
not really
okay a couple like physical like
altercations with men just that's what
you mean that's just dating you know
being a white woman do people want to
hit you and
what does it mean no I mean I like I'm
trying to think now you'll be hitting
them first don't you not no never never
I'm actually not like that they choke
you it it's it's not I mean I had like
an assault you know like right because
you really just gotta squirm out it's
more about squirming you know okay you
got you can squirm you can pinch you can
bite like that's really what women can
more do I'm not gonna knock someone out
you know oh women hit hard that's that's
what's left on about women women are a
lot of women are heavy-handed correct
okay so I opened for Dane Cook once at
the Laugh Factory your spot George
Floyd's uh uh don't bring him up no more
during this I can't hear the name George
Floyd
one take yeah you know
two girls in the front beautiful blonde
girls that were like 24. yeah
nightmare to have in a taping yeah you
know I mean they're drinking they know
they're gonna be on camera you know no
one's ever told them to shut up
everyone's always laughed at their jokes
so they could fuck them like they think
they're funny so they would every time I
would say a joke they go and then that
happened to me like they would weigh in
I hate that shit yeah helpful heckling
that's not helpful at all yeah yeah and
they would look at each other we got
that out but I was like yeah or they
would be like that's so true like as if
I needed them to corroborate yeah and
then so I go up and I told Dane and I
was like you're doing one take this is a
problem like they said something after
everyone and if it was just like a show
I wouldn't say shit and like whatever
someone's gonna say someone put a dick
in their mouth or kick them out or
something like and taping and so I said
I told them and so then I think someone
was going on after maybe Gary Goldman or
something and then so they removed the
girls you know said you have to leave
they were not fucking having it we're
not fucking leaving security guards
always say girls are the biggest problem
because they know they can hit you and
you can't hit them back yeah you know
and they can scream and if you're too
rough with them you're the bully yeah
like when I started before I was kind of
known I was able to kick girls out and
make fun of them and whatever but now
it's like you can lose the room real
fast if you're too hard on a girl who
has to get up and leave whatever and so
there was a guy Laugh Factory he used to
have this his rail this guy that was in
the Israeli Army like who was the
Bouncer and these girls they didn't want
to get kicked out they were like you
know on whatever combination of fucking
Adderall and you know anorexia and like
whatever made their brains think this
was a good idea this girl hit him in the
face like just went for him he just an
instinct like he just went boom punched
her right between the eyes her knees
buckled like you know those toys that
have wooden that you put your thumb in
it and they just like she just went down
like her head went at the same time as
her knees it was fucking wild and it was
just like an instinct yeah you know and
it was like a nightmare and whatever but
like it hitting a man you don't you
don't know who's just gonna hit you back
yeah like it's not
yeah Southern um so how'd you deal with
this ax
I think for me
of their own like I come from a lot of
like sexual abuse so I think you always
have your own little like exit strategy
or like you're really nice until you're
near a door or you you know what I mean
like you find a way to just be safe you
know yeah or like get out of the
situation so sometimes it's not about
fighting back sometimes it's about
cooperating until you can like
easily Escape
this episode is brought to you by
kerryuma the cool sustainable sneakers
loved by Surfers and skateboarding their
reimagining classic sneakers with you
and the planet in mind spring has
officially sprung and we're trading out
the boots and cold weather kicks for
something a little lighter and brighter
crafted with organic cotton canvas and
spring Shades like rose off-white and
green are best seller Ocha low is sure
to become your staple shoe of the season
and lucky for you they just cleared a 77
000 person wait list that's wild with 10
plus colorways bold prints and
collaborations with Brands like Avatar
Pantone those are the ones that I just
ordered there's a pair for every
personality and all of my personalities
with over 33 000 five-star reviews
there's no wonder this Ultra comfy and
celeb favorite style is flying off the
shelves the biggest difference between
these sneakers in your old sneakers Oka
is actually comfortable no blisters with
custom designed Cork and memory foam
insoles to ensure a perfect fit carry
you Uma is a b Corp certified
sustainable sneaker company they're
known for their reforestation efforts in
the Brazilian Rainforest their
co-founders David and Fernando both grew
up in Brazil so this project is
especially close to home for every pair
of sneakers sold kurumia plants two
trees and they've already planted over 2
million to date that's so cool Kerry
Yuma ships all their sneakers free and
fast in the USA and offers worldwide
shipping and 60-day free returns they
deliver right to your front door using a
single box and with cycled packaging I
am completely obsessed with these and
for a limited time good for you
listeners can get an exclusive 15 off
your pair of carry Yuma sneakers go to
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com Whitney to get 15 off
c-a-r-i-u-m-i-a.com Whitney for 15 off
only for a limited time and stop stop
wearing the shoes you're wearing they're
not working these are better
man I had a girl uh I had a girlfriend
like my last girlfriend like my last
like official girlfriend when did you
break it out so 14 or some shit why'd
you break up
um she was just a big baby I just
couldn't do it you know like she was I
don't know I used to always say about
her I said oh um I feel like I'm
finishing
um trying to raise like finishing
whatever the fuck her father didn't do
yep like it was like that like with her
well anyway I felt like she was like
pouty she was like tan for me and all
this shit or whatever and then she was
like
she had like a temper and all this shit
or whatever and like at the beginning
was there something sexy about it or
like nah I don't I don't I don't I don't
fuck with like
problems and confrontation or whatever
like I'm I'm not like that or whatever
so she uh but I feel like she wanted I
feel like she wanted that I feel like
she wanted that that was passion to her
and that's probably what she saw yeah
and she said before before me like her
ex-boyfriend used to just like hit her
and all this shit or whatever and I
didn't I didn't I never ever put my hand
on a woman at all but I said I said oh I
can see why he would do that
you know like that shit yeah I don't
know so I feel like she kind of wanted
that kind of relationship and I'm like
nah if I if I hit a chick I wouldn't
like feel like too good about it I
sparred like you know in the boxing gym
when I was Far like light and all that
shit but like real life I'm like yeah no
it's a it's It's Tricky like I
definitely have those people in my life
that you're like you are addicted to
this whether it's a self-righteous
ending Nation or and I've seen it with
Comics too sometimes where like things
are going too well and there's like like
they need their outsides to match their
insides or you know and they have to
create drama and just like fucking shoot
themselves in the foot or something or
they have to like make the shoe drop so
they don't have to wait for the shoe to
drop like they kind of just want to like
blow shit because we need something to
fight against that's what made us a dope
uh you know at the um you know in the
first place yep and it's also totally
and I think that also adrenaline makes
dopamine so for a lot of people that
kind of fighting like it actually you
get high off of it yeah
you feel like you know it's like a
legitimate neurochemical reaction yeah
yeah yeah but like you're so smart that
you don't I remember when Dr Andrew
huberman was on he's a big
neuroscientist he said he's like you
know he said the word emotional
contagion like when you're like he's
like in a relationship I will not be
emotionally recruited into someone's
emotional contagion because like if
you're in a relationship with someone
and they have that shit going on like
I'll just be like I'm not participating
in this because to me it's like that's
like adrenaline it takes three days for
the adrenaline to wear off and to not be
in that you know what I mean I don't
want to be that's real it's like yeah
it's also exhausting yeah I don't want
to be tired
work I don't want to be tired and also
like you know for me unless I'm getting
like tons of jokes out of it like
there's no yeah need for this but I see
so many
Comics like Lou and whatever of all jobs
like botched their fucking lives and
careers because they're sidelined by
these relationships that just vampires
that just like suck their energy suck
their time and suck their relationships
also make people fat
you ever noticed that like people start
picking up like people start getting
lazy because somebody accept them and
assorted and then so I I had a lot of
pubes yeah I had someone that was so
head over heels over me that I grew my
pubes back damn man
how'd you feel how did you feel like yo
this ain't me I well here's the thing I
had them lasered so long ago I didn't
even think they could come back you know
like every now and then I would just
sort of like clean up you know and uh
he he's also like a little bit younger
and he is like into that he was like why
have you shit like he's oddly like he's
younger he like hairy pussy
I'm trying to say it anymore elegant way
I mean but he basically was like he's
younger and he's kind of like the shave
thing feels kind of like
pedophile how it's like attached to a
grown-ass woman
shit but he just kind of was like I
think that if you're younger and you
kind of came up on porn where you only
saw shaved pussies from the beginning
you know and now you're kind of like
it's kinkier to have some I don't know
hair I don't know
my gynecologist three years ago told me
the number one request coming in is
plugs for women's vaginas who had
lasered it and wanted pubes again
because pubes are back oh shit cheers he
was a bat son
like don't like there's something did
you come up on like Playboy like what
did you look at you probably saw pubes
the first time you saw a naked woman did
she have pups uh
uh yeah yeah you know what it was I came
up around
I came up around a lot a lot of mixed
girls so uh so they would grow hair and
where did you grow up company or like
South Central I love it like I love the
toxicity of comedian relationships where
you're friends with someone and you know
nothing about them until you do a
podcast together it's all good it's oh
where are you from DC Virginia West
Virginia oh okay oh it depends on the
day oh okay yeah depends on the fight I
want to win yeah if I said yeah if I
said oh hey I'm I grew up in the east
side low bottoms nobody knows what that
is but if I said hey you know it's
Compton yeah like do you notice that
like in areas like that now they're
starting to rename neighborhoods like
Compton Meadows yeah yeah I'm like ain't
nothing guarding me about this
motherfucker Orchid Circle yeah like
where's that and someone's like Cesar
Chavez and MLK Boulevard I'm like look
at this Compton I ordered it's like
Washington Heights it's like not you in
Harlem like yeah I know and then you're
like I guess I don't know about you know
it's like it's just like all like Swan
Lake like what what's the cross street
yeah like where they got nipsy like what
like how about no it's not sanitize it
until we're out of the woods shall we
yeah so uh what was that did you ever
leave la
foreign
like the first time I ever like left La
left La it was a comedy I went to New
York for like three months or whatever
in 2010
or whatever because I couldn't I
couldn't um it's weird because like I
couldn't like leave the state or
whatever because I was like a Warder to
court for so like long or whatever you
talk can you talk about why yeah sure I
mean you know I'm you know my you know
my family had a past or whatever so uh
so my mom had problems or whatever she's
clean out but you know she had problems
and all this shit or whatever so like um
that's awesome you know yeah so I was
like Mike so I was in like a water to
court but my auntie took care of me and
all that shit I live with my aunts oh
for real that's wild for how long um I
went uh I my mom
um uh was Now call it um and uh I was
basically separate my sister and I we
ran away from home wow yeah like oh 10
and 11. some white people shit
run away
they be doing shit like fucking sneaking
out of the house and tying a bunch of
t-shirts together rolling out of the
motherfucking window all kind of shit
I'm running away put pillows in the bed
like it's a body
my parents don't check you just put
pillows down like my mom won't notice
for 12 years like now I'm a great I'm an
awesome comedian and when he comes he's
like what the fuck happened I've been
through the room sleep but I think
there's something very unique about
people that were raised by other family
members that were not their parents
because I was sent away to a place
called Roanoke Virginia super super
country to a farm to go live with my
aunts that's why you like horses and
shit because they they kind of raise me
like I kind of humans I did not
understand them I was told I was on the
Spectrum I was autistic I was
traumatized I was shut down I was dumb
whatever but like human behavior I just
could not understand but animal behavior
is always uh the motive is always
congress with the with the body language
and the energy so I think I grew up like
with a very I mean alcoholism it'll
fucking get you dude people are lying
people are you go to church and they're
like respect your neighbor don't cheat
and then I'm being dragged around to
Mistresses houses like I'm I it like
nothing ever fucking added up and your
life was turned up and it was confusing
but animals are never confusing if you
understand and I started like learning
their body language and their behaviors
and like herds and packs are like
nothing if not fair and I always just
felt like no one fought fair and no one
and people use like guilt to control
each other and throw in bottles and
fighting each other and I just was like
I don't fuck humans are like not they
don't have their shit together but
that's what makes us apex predators
you know like and that's what we are you
know so you have a gun in your hand yeah
I do think there's a little bit like
we're kind of superficially at the top
of the food chain if we have guns and
fences and cages but like as soon as
it's you in a Bobcat alone
no no no like humans can get killed by
bees yeah yeah bees can kill us
actually not even that we'll kill
ourselves you'll fucking put
we'll eat shit that kills us we are the
only species that confines themselves we
put ourselves in Zoo
all kind of shit but being raised by
your odds did your aunt have children
yeah she had um she had a son he was
like three years older than me and then
a little bit later she had a she had a
daughter and so I lived with them from
age of five
through eight and then from 11 through
19.
so yeah because your dad um around never
seen this nigga in my life you know I
told you I can't no no no no that's
racist that's not true that's not true
but uh people in Compton definitely if
you ever had the urge to reach out I
asked my mom she always like shut me
down and shit she'd always be like ah
just stop asking me shit like that I've
moved on I'm like what
what
and I was like fuck it and then one time
recently I asked her I said Mama who my
daddy and then she was like one day I'm
gonna one day I'm gonna show you who the
fuck your daddy is and you are gonna
regret you ask me it's just Michael
Jordan I know right
yo so but would you like would you be
able to find him on your own like 23 of
me can you even do he'd have to have
done it too probably but here's the
thing he probably what is he dead
what I know like like what if he's dead
I don't know what do you feel like what
does your gut tell you so I had a
feeling I feel like we kind of know on
this fucked up level I had a feeling
maybe like four years ago that a piece
of me died
like I don't know what it was but I
wasn't doing the original room at The
Comedy Store a lot during this time for
a lot of pieces of me died
like I just remember being in New York
and I was just something like damn man I
said I don't know what the fuck this is
whenever I'm like I don't I don't feel
right or whatever or something like that
like I feel like like something
physiological was like happening but I'm
it's not nothing like no Health shit I
wasn't like man like something you know
and I and I was like what if this nigga
is dead you know like and you know I
don't know my sister and I we were
separated like in a really like they
basically in the divorce my dad took my
sister and my mom took me which is like
kind of unheard of like I mean like
instead of doing like you know weekends
or dad weekdays or Mom they just
separated us and uh and then we were
estranged for literally 25 years sister
we just like when my mom died were able
to re-engage because we just we couldn't
before everyone was dead because it was
just there was such a fucked up Web of
Lies and it was just like too fraught
and uh and there are times like we've
gone through dates where like she had
been sick or had admitted to the
hospital or like and I had these like
episodes where I would like wake up
crying and have night terrors and it was
like the same like pit in my stomach and
something was happening to her and she
was in danger she was like in you know
yeah I think that's just real like when
my mom when my dad died I knew it I knew
it the second I had landed he was in a
nursing home he had had a stroke and he
couldn't move whatever and he and uh as
soon as he died I knew like I just I
just knew I was in the airport and I
just knew it and then my phone started
ringing and I didn't because I knew it
and then I just drove straight to like a
wolf sanctuary but it's like my body
just like knew it was wild yeah I had
just seen him he was like actually doing
a little bit better I landed and then I
just like felt it your mom not here no
more either mom no she died in December
oh may all year like apparently I mean
yeah much respect but I'm like oh damn
that's crazy I mean I still got my mom
or whatever so I mean that's not some
cold shit you know well I mean I can't
imagine it was actually kind of like
Wilder when they were alive like as
fucked up as that is and I think it's
like a lot of people feel this way even
though it's going to make me seem like a
psychopath to people that have not had
like like rough situations with their
parents which is like my mom had a
stroke the month my I had a sitcom like
start and uh and she was in a bed for
almost 10 years like had to carry to the
bathroom like just like Nightmare and
then my dad had a stroke a year later
and was like from the neck down six
years so I spent most of my time for the
past like 10 years like on the road and
in between that at icus and hospitals
and nursing homes and like I just that's
where I spent a ton of time and that
shit like
it's hard to find people like to date
and it's hard to be copacetic and even
friendship sometimes because when you've
sort of like
been around that much sadness and had to
be so high functioning and be around so
much grief it's kind of hard to deal
with people like I am in I have drama I
am traumatized by Elon Musk took my
check mark and you're just like yeah
yeah I can't relate to a lot of people
facts yeah yeah damn that's crazy I do
like that you don't got to be from the
hood to go through some to go through
some wild shit you know what I'm saying
like because that that's the that's the
stigma you know I'm saying like oh man
he from he's from Compton I know your
life must I'm like well ask a chick from
Virginia DC like well that's like I mean
it's I I you're just Case by case and
I'm not gonna like be up here and go
like I've had it harder than you know
being white is like whatever like you
know but no matter about the colors and
why homeless in a fucked up way it was
weird because I the cops would come to
the house and I remember always going
like why won't they take us I remember
being like please take us but I think
that when it's like white the white
parent they're like oh you know we'll
leave I'm like take us like I felt like
what is it gonna take for you to take us
you know what I mean yo that remind me
of like how uh okay so
when I was like eight uh my mom had got
her shit together oh it was dope she's
got her shit together and so I'm gonna
go live with her in Inglewood it was
great for about six months were you
aware at the time that she was
struggling with something or no I don't
know I don't think about it you know I
didn't think about it like I I didn't
like my cousin she's like oh that's why
your mom doing this and I'll be like I
don't even know what the fuck that is I
just died you just are like as a kid
you're like oh sometimes mom sleeps on
the floor and I like to sleep on the
floor sometimes mommy has like a black
eye like a funny makeup like you just
don't put it together yeah we're so dumb
his kids it's so heartbreaking because
his kids were so relentlessly hopeful
you know what I mean we give a lot of
Grace
and I think that our psyche like kind of
and this isn't always a good thing but
can sort of like like figure out a way
to just fucking um uh find resolve
alchemize something bad into like oh no
it's just this like the chances of it
being the explanation you're coming up
alternative it's Halloween she's she's
practicing her Halloween costume yeah
that's why she has two black eyes yeah
yeah and passed on the floor shit yeah
but you're like as a kid you're like I
can't handle the fact that she drinks
this liquid that makes her fall down the
stairs so I'm gonna go with the raccoon
costume thing facts yep and then so uh
but I remind me of like how like so
anyway so you got her shit together and
then she ain't got she had un got her
shit together and then I got put into an
orphanage right and the orphanage was
lit it was great you know I always talk
about this on everybody it was fucking
great orphanage is such a is a word it's
different than like
you'd like foster care what's the
difference uh foster care is a house
yeah and this orphanage was five acres
and it was like you know different like
it was like five it was like seven
different seven different cottages on
this side and then seven different
cottages on this side and then like the
offices were on that side and we were in
an orphan per se but I think it was an
orphanage I mean but I just like the it
was actually a residential oh okay yeah
and so how did you get in there oh so I
was I was gonna get to that is that um
you know my mom like you know I called
the wagon so then I had uh something
like these white people one day I came
home from school and they was like in my
mama living room and Angelina Jolie was
just in your mom's living room waiting
oh God and I was like oh hell yeah like
Angelina like I heard she'd be fucking
family members like let's go like like I
like uh like yeah and Alex's hair has
always been cool I mean that kid is
always had a mohawk what's up with him
I don't know they're all I mean they're
I don't know what are you doing now I
like in general don't want to know
anything about children's lives yeah
yeah but when people are like did you
see Angelina's daughter's now a boat I'm
like I don't know anything about anyone
I think there was a minute where that
might have happened during the pandemic
everyone changed everything my hair was
blue it's fine everybody I transitioned
into a everybody changing gender in a
pandemic I know into a lesbian bookstore
owner so everybody change their signs
can you be trans like astrology sign
being a Virgo gives me a lot of shit I
get so much shit for it but we have our
day September what fourth fourth oh
Beyonce birthday yes
I usually by the way I usually celebrate
the fifth because Beyonce's is the
fourth and you know what's I got to do
with you she's just it's her birthday I
celebrate her birthday how you gonna
give you a birthday up to her that's
like Alicia Keys got my birthday and I'm
like this is my birthday what's your
birthday January 25th oh that's a good I
want to talk about that yeah I'm an
aquarius whatever the fuck that means so
in the orphanage you were eight
oh yeah yeah so anyway so I moved into
orphanage but then by the time I was
about to leave or whatever and I had I
was like there was like yo man we're
gonna put you back with your auntie and
I was like damn it and I said man Nathan
got to go to a white family I want to go
with these people you know anyways I'm
with an auntie
so I went back he's with an aunt yeah so
I moved back to Baldwin Hills with my
auntie and what was like I mean the idea
was to just go back to your mom you know
are you glad because if you had gone
with some white family they would have
got you yeah they would have cut your
brain out and put it in some old man or
or it could have been like Blind Side
where they you know took care of a guy
who liked
it came out of stand-up comic or
whatever the fuck or whatever I don't
know like I got a friend who um I got a
friend he's a comic too but they taught
his wife family taught him gymnastics
and now he can backflip he's a big black
dude who can backflip by the way so can
you yeah that's true they taught me a
lot in the ornaments
the white families came in and you're
just doing backflips yeah I was trying
to get I was trying to get scouted like
Scouts came not not family Scouts yeah
we're gonna get this thing your
Christmas card is gonna be slamming if
you adopt me do you remember a time like
in the orphanage or where you were being
funny like where you were like try to
entertain or like do you feel like the
roots of you being a performer one time
um one time I didn't have a toy to share
whatever so we used to have these uh
days at school called share day and I'd
have a toy so I was like man I'm gonna
do two minutes of stand-up comedy and I
went up there I ate a dick so hard I had
a day so hard I was trying to uh but
you're performing for kids yeah kids and
my two teachers kids are a terrible
audience
like Google
to the ah you don't know Gaga oh that's
right you guys were taking his babies
you guys didn't get there what's the
deal with cabbage patch cat they live in
a Cabbage Patch yeah but then I was like
putting like I was I was doing plays and
all that shit and uh one time I think
Gary a a staff member named Gary he took
us on an outing and uh he actually took
us to a comedy club but it wasn't like
like he didn't take us like to a um to a
show it was like he was a comic he went
there during the day I don't remember
what the comedy club was but I do know
that it was the only Comedy Club I know
that is day shows is well it's time to
Comedy Club Jumbo's Clown it wasn't a
day show oh it was like it was like it
was just open during the day that he
went in there he just took you there
because he had to do some shit yeah but
it wasn't just me it took like me and
like five more kids or whatever I do
remember this and I'm like damn like you
know this is a comedy club oh I didn't
even think like someone gets so much
attention there's like a light on them
and if someone interrupts security
removes them I I like this Arrangement
facts this is like they have a light on
here but it was like daytime but it was
like daytime or whatever so he was there
just talking to his friend or whoever
the fuck ran that thing and we you know
like five I was just running around and
shit talking or whatever and all this
stuff and a couple of us were like on
stage like running around and all that
stuff but it wasn't like we didn't go up
and do time and then you go did you okay
so then you left the orphanage and then
at what point were you like I want to be
a performer
um I I mean that was before that was in
the hood I mean yeah that was in the
hood like where I um I was being I was
being funny in class and then um
somebody said oh you should be one of
them people who make people laugh and
were you watching like how many movies
so Pete so peep so I uh you saw Steve
Martin and that was it no yeah I love Mr
Steve Martin We're not gonna get into it
Steve Martin earlier I think Steve
Martin the motherfucking genius and
Whitney I think he's an arrow on your
head really I was like you mad you
didn't think of it have you thought
about that shit you'd have been like yo
I should put an arrow on my head dude I
can't put an arrow on my head I have the
carrot and bond extensions man my scalp
is showing I got I got to have the I
have black shoe polish on my let me see
your hair it would just like let me see
how shit look watch this look look this
is what happens when I rub my scalp
it's just black tar oh man she doing
blackheads like everybody she doing
blackheads black scallops on black Scout
no I think that like there's a lot of
great comedic actors who are brilliant
brilliant The Jerk Roxanne Dirty Rotten
Scoundrels like Steve Martin is the best
of the best Three Amigos one of my
favorites but like trying to remake it
uh but as stand up stand up I guess for
me what I enjoy about stand up is like a
little bit of a cerebral
take also so not something just feels
like someone being wacky oh what about
Jim Carrey uh I don't like I'm gonna say
something crazy I don't really know a
lot of his stand-up oh really he just
you never seen a natural act like I saw
like when he would I mean when he would
be at the store and he would do
um Fire Marshall Bill and he would do
all these Impressions you saw him at the
store no there's like video of that shit
and there's audio in the in The Comedy
Store of 50 50th Anniversary record like
listening to it but I think for me for
whatever reason I guess I kind of like
the only way I was able to
convince myself that I was capable of
doing stand-up or could make it is that
oh all these people that are really
overthinking uh like obsessively
neurotic that sort of like right
like I could do that I didn't have
confidence in myself as like a performer
who could just like like ride was you
silly in the back of the classroom or
did you have no smart ass mouth nope I
was like no I was a fucking the most
studious like want to be perfect
Straight A's like terrified of getting
rejected or embarrassed like I don't
really like I had a like because you
know like the schools I went to it's
like the tuition wasn't paid and like
all there was always some bullshit and
there was never money for the field
trips and I was always the kid that like
had to stay back because I didn't have
my lunch was always fucking just wet for
no reason it's like when you grow up in
alcoholic home your shit's just
embarrassing all the time so I was like
always just trying to you grow up poor
yeah but even more fucked is that I
thought we were Rich it was it was it
was why poor it was like in debt but
overspending you know and then my mom
worked at a department store so we had
nice stuff but that she got for free
from department store and then I would
spend every day after school and on the
weekends in Bloomingdale's with her so I
was around nice stuff so I felt like we
were rich and she drank white wine all
day and I thought that was like what
rich people I think you guys were rich
well when like the car gets taken and
the house we had like had to get you
know we got we had to leave school like
because we didn't pay the tuition you
know I got sent home like they would put
these
um safety pins that's why the safety pin
tattoo uh of like the the what's it
called like the bill for like the amount
they would take me out of school and
like send me home like you have to leave
you know I haven't paid tuition you know
shit like that you know so it was like I
think on some level money might have
been coming in and out but it wasn't
there was no food in the fridge like I I
kind of thought that was normal and then
you go to someone else's house and
you're like oh there's like food in the
fridge like that's you know so I think
that there was a lot of like what seemed
like nice art and like glass vases but
did you ever have to ask to go into the
refrigerator
or could you just go into your
refrigerator well no one was ever around
like I caught on fire when I was a kid
because I should be caught on fire so
the the so we had a house you were set
on fire yourself I okay so we had a
house but there was never the the AC was
never paid or the the Heat or the
whatever so it was always so cold that I
would get on top of the oven where
there's the four burners and I would
change clothes in the morning because I
was always so cold and so I was standing
there changing and my nightgown caught
on fire and I was like some Emily Rose
shit what's that is that a Emily Rose oh
she had Jennifer Carpenter I think is
that she's a friend of mine damn that's
crazy but so it's like it was this thing
where it's like in my head it was like a
nice house to me but it you know some
poor shit was going on you know what I'm
saying it was all about like the keeping
up with the Joneses like it was all
about sort of like for the amount of
money this I bet we could have like a
one bedroom house and actually eat
instead of this thing that's trying to I
always felt like my parents were trying
to give off the idea that we figured
till we make it and then I lived in
apartment with my mom after the divorce
like we lived in a really small
apartment you know so how many bedrooms
is that two but one of them was like an
office so we shared a bedroom oh yeah
when you're like as a teenager sharing a
tiny bathroom with your mom it's hard to
like
tolerate it's just like a tree it's just
like you know there wasn't space okay so
so you then go into like high school you
get when are you like I'm a comedian uh
I was 18 turning 19 and uh and who did
you see besides your hero Steve Martin
Steve Martin is a God and I will not let
you I'm not I'm just the legend he
wasn't my he was as a comedian actor
Martin I saw him Three Amigos my
favorite what
Steve Martin special in my life up here
look up very important part of my
childhood and adulthood uh scene from uh
uh Three Amigos I just hit stand up I
never really saw and if I saw it I
probably would have not crazy definitely
not gonna appreciate it now no one wants
to see women being kooky they already
think we're kooky no I like Lucille Ball
Lucille Ball's a genius yeah but that's
not stand up
stand up is different uh are there no
physical women comedians would be
flopping all over the floor no people
when we fall people like worry she okay
it's not funny it's not a physical
comedian out there I mean I definitely
am
like I might I mean I miss I can't think
so you just go hard hard hard yeah but
like I'm definitely like more I move
around more I mean that's
then more I don't lean against a wall
and talk a lot of women Comics that are
physical they make faces by the way
Maria banford in a way like but that's
she does voices no but yeah it's like no
one wants to see a woman be like I'm
crazy lady I do but whatever no one I
mean oh Phyllis Diller was silly like
Phyllis Diller was like very uh uh you
know what's the word um
mindful about her looking funny like she
would cut her boots right at her leg
where it was the funniest and she would
dress like a bird and make her like she
was like knew she had to look at Judy to
nuda like wore fucking fruit on her head
and would do dumb like dances and shit
but I don't think she's like
you know she doesn't get sort of we need
the Chris Brown of woman comedy out
there not not hitting women but don't
don't fight other women but like but
he's back flipping and physical and well
I should never say Chris Brown that's a
terrible fucking example I just was
trying to go with someone that can
bounce back from an allegation but but
yeah I just don't I looked at Steve
Martin I was like I feel like guys can
do this and it's funny but I don't think
anyone wants to see a girl like be silly
because they're like and then why aren't
you having kids what do you think okay
well what about females who do like
improv and they be goofied in a
motherfucker
I mean improv in general I think is more
of uh exercise than right art
okay you know I can actually buy that
okay I'll buy that did you do ever do
like improv classes I think your
products are good to take I just as like
a art I don't I don't know about that oh
yeah like is there like some career
improvers so y'all so you're just gonna
guess
yeah
sit down and write or prepare
go guess
level of self-indulgence like I'm just
gonna like me flying by the seat of my
pants is just art dude yeah no I took a
lot of I took a lot of improv classes
early on and shit I think I did that
right before I did like actual stand-up
and shit because I just want to be like
funny I wish I had done that yeah that
shit is fun but like freeze your mind up
did you did you struggle with it or were
you able to just instantly be free no I
was because I was already hyper and shit
that's what I I just wanted to while out
that's what I wanted to do so I was cool
see I feel like there was I had such a
structureless upbringing like I remember
when I was like did some improv things
maybe UCB or something and it was kind
of like improv improving like yell
something from the audience and it was
kind of okay funny but I remember being
like what if we just stopped and just
spent 10 minutes writing and sketched
and then did it
I know what I'm doing but you're fucking
a mess you're trying to like you're the
fucking you know fucking guy that won't
pass the ball yeah and like you're the
one that always goes for the weird dick
joke like I just was like why don't we
go back and just write it out yeah like
delicious for 10 minutes and we'll have
a fucking great sketch like I couldn't
wrap my head around improvising
something that was a B minus when we
could just go write something to be an A
plus I've never seen a I've never seen
an adult Ass Like A Plus improv oh I saw
one in the ground pupil
Rob Riggle Daniel Schneider those guys
are fucking it seems scripted it's so
good actually the growlings does great
see I haven't I auditioned for the
Groundlings I have so much respect for
like who came out of the ground lease
Lisa Kudrow like
I went there and they were like you need
to improvise the monologue as an animal
and I literally was like it's been a
pleasure like I'm just not
I had been in an acting class where I
had to be inhabit an animal and I'm like
I'm just no more rug burn on my knee
like I'm not I can't you're a you're a
real comic I just was like there's just
I like how do you guys respect me less
than I respect myself like you guys
didn't even vacuum this shit like I'm
not doing this I'm not gonna humiliate
like I will suck your dick for a job but
I'm not gonna be a worm a funny worm
that's crazy man because I'd be a worm
in a minute
oh a little earthworm I was with a guy
I like I'm like that's my jam like I
guess to me like I heard this and it
really resonated with me like I think
Chris Rock said this I don't know I
attribute every like incisive quote
about stand up to Chris is that
comedians become comedians to control
how we're embarrassed
okay so so afraid of embarrassment that
we have to like control I'm gonna
embarrass myself this way yeah because I
know you're gonna make fun of me for
this this I'm gonna get to it before you
get to it yeah my last name is Cummings
whatever like all that shit like I had
to get ahead of it you know because of
the the fear of embarrassment and to me
going to do improv just felt like this
is embarrassing the whole point of doing
this is to seem really cool yeah
like but if I'm on the Fly I can't
prepare yeah yeah yeah I guess so but
it's like what is the difference like
between
stand up in terms of the personality
type since you've done both
I don't know I mean one can do the other
but I think the other can't do the other
yeah that's what I hear a lot about
improv people like like improv like oh I
could never do stand up that is just uh
correct you know but this we can always
go we can go in anybody's World they say
that standards make the Great ACT uh
make the best actors I agree I totally
agree with that someone that just gave a
thrilling performance
accused and why uh oh no I'm joking it's
a show on Fox oh okay I guess it's well
just because it's um It's a drama
and I got raped it's like a rape drama
and you got raped when this happened
it's on the fox show what yeah I know
you got it right let me look this up
well I don't want to look at rape up
wait is it on video to read well it's on
the TV show oh yeah I thought it got
raped in real life in any I did but that
wasn't filmed oh okay that was just in
an apartment in Philadelphia oh man
Philly wow man them niggas booed me I
can imagine what the fuck they did for
your ass in an apartment too and then
made him famous when you get booed in
Philly you are become the best I wish
they would have failed my shit because
it means one of the greatest I mean
honestly I feel like stand-up comedy
changed like all of a sudden the grades
like Bill Burr turned into a rock star
after that Opie and Anthony tour where
he you've seen it obviously where he's
getting so basically the Opie and
Anthony fans which I don't know like did
you kind of follow Howard Stern and Opie
and Anthony a little bit just a little
bit that was like such a big deal in
comedy for the longest time if you
weren't the kind of comic that we get on
The Tonight Show or you know whatever
get a sitcom you would do Howard Stern
Opie and Anthony you know it was kind of
I feel like like a different like an
older version of like Legion of skanks
you know or like the podcast like you
know super popular like hardcore comedy
fans but like people think they're kind
of like dirty and or something and like
uh and uh they would do this tour open
Anthony tour and the fans were just
Savage like it was just like brutal they
booed Dom herera off the stage they
booed someone else and billboard was
backstage just like fuck this like I'm
doing my 12 minutes yeah I'm not getting
good and Philly fans I lived in Philly
there's a jail cell underneath the eagle
stadium for Eagles fans that lose their
shit like they don't so he's they're
getting he's getting booed so hard and
then he stays up there like getting
boots I'm doing my time six minutes
foreign
I hope you get herpes and then he's
trashing every sacred part of
Philadelphia sports Philadelphia lore
Philadelphia movies and then he slowly
just starts killing yeah get some
killing killing to the point where it's
like he kind of didn't even it was just
like it's one of the most captivating
things I've ever yeah
yeah yeah it's like a it's like uh
remember when Bernie you ever heard a
story about Def Jam and Bernie Mac uh
where everybody was like bombing and
bombing and bombing and Bernie Mac came
on or something like I ain't scared of
you motherfuckers that's because they
were bullying everybody before so he was
like are you scared of you motherfuckers
and here's my joke and after he do it he
was like I ain't scared of you
motherfuckers that's like Bill Burr's
version of like yeah four minutes not
doing it fuck Rocky yeah I mean it's
also it's like yeah there's it's taken
me so long as a comedian to where if
things are going sideways it I do know
if you're Wild on an audience like that
like were you like let me talk to you
real quick there are some times in the
or that I feel like a couple Comics have
witnessed there was one time where it
was like I was doing excellent it was I
finally like had cracked the or and it
was like my safe place like in the OR in
The Comedy Store is like you know it's
like the smaller room that's darker
that's sort of more the sort of like
gritty gym like there's a lot of
distractions there's a window where you
can look at on Sunset but it's kind of
like you know your energy decides and
it's so contagious in there like it's
like if you come up with weird energy
everybody feels it you know like the
room can go sideways so fast also you're
defenseless because the way that Mitzi
Shore lit it you actually can't see the
audience you want it to be that way so
Comics wouldn't lean on crowd work you
know but it's just it's kind of like how
would you describe the or it's just like
it kind of fucks with your head it
psyches you out a bit because of how
it's lit ah
look all I know is that I told
um all I know is that I emailed the uh
the booker and I said don't ever put me
in the OR again I said I'm a main room
comic put me in there I don't fuck with
the or the or is like it's like the only
way I can describe it is it's like
sexual it's like you gotta know who
you're having sex with and you can't
just do what worked with the last person
facts right you got it if they're weird
you gotta go with them but you know like
Sebastian would get on stage after like
Joey Diaz or well you know after hit he
was shaking the fucking building and
would just pace for like 40 seconds just
reset the energy because you can't
there's no momentum between Comics you
could do a thing where um I used to do a
thing where I would come on stage and
then I would uh you know the little
tables right there and I would just lay
down
you gotta you gotta out Alpha them
because they are in the power position
yeah yeah and they can see through you
it's like the way that it's lit you
can't just do jokes yeah you know like
it's it's hard to explain and also
there's something that's like weirdly
like a mind fuck about the or because
there's always Comics you respect in the
back but you can't see them yeah I mean
all the comics you know it's like
there's a door of someone like the work
in the cover Booth who's like a younger
comment we even I want the door guys to
think I'm funny right I don't want them
like seeing me eat shit and oh you know
it's like like I should have figured
this room out by now you know but that
room taught me that it's always your
fault like you gotta fix it like you've
got to figure it out you know yeah
because otherwise you just will bomb
every night in that room yeah and
um I forgot where I was even talking
about this I don't know but I used to go
in there I just go in there just like
that like one no shirt the first time I
was going there with no fucking shirt on
and I would just be like anyway just do
my fucking jokes because I was like you
know if I'm gonna be here and I'm gonna
do this I was like I gotta I was like
it's me you know what that room taught
me it taught me about my try too hard
energy
I didn't realize that I gave off
desperate like try hard energy yeah like
that room you got to do like 20 30 of
what you would do in the in terms of
energy did you okay okay let's talk
about the tryhard energy did you think I
do want to know what happened in Philly
but we'll get to it
um I just bombed on black but what's his
name black uh Black Thought Black
Thought or whatever uh he liked my album
that I did or whatever so he flew me out
to Philly or whatever and then I just
you know I'm I don't know I I didn't do
well did you go up before music
nah no no no man I just went up
and I and I just didn't do well was it a
comedy venue
it was a it was me it was just one thing
I will say though it's it's once you
start getting known people will ask you
to do things that are not con their
environments that aren't conducive to
Comedy like I recently got I got asked
to do corporate gigs and they're like
it's like good money and they're like
all right you're on the side of this
mountain in Utah and you're gonna do 20
minutes after the investors talk about
their returns and then you're gonna
introduce them and it's like when am I
gonna fucking learn like this is not an
environment conducive to Comedy yeah and
so I gotta just say no to that shit now
as much as I want to like your Heroes
will be like will you open for me on the
road like musicians and I'm like nah
dude yeah cause I'm not that's not how
it works yeah yeah come try to do your
shit in the or it's not going to go well
you know what's so funny is that like
I've been running like like Comics who
are um the comics who are like not like
I'm not saying like like I I am this
thing or whatever but in like some
Comics I'll be like hey man can you come
you know and and I'll I'll still go and
do it and I'll be like what are you
doing like in my head but I'm gonna say
I gotta get that time I can't I will I
find myself driving downtown to do like
a Chipotle comedy night and I'm like
what am I doing yeah why can't I say no
yeah yeah I I can't the people like
people reach out to me the book shows or
I get 10 a day from some random fucking
people aren't even programmed and want
to come do this open mic and Santa
Clarita and I'm like yeah I'll be there
it's at 4 15 on a Tuesday I'll be there
and I'm like what am I doing I'm like we
don't gotta do that everybody what is
that you need that time you know we're
like stage fiends we're like like but
don't you think that that's a good thing
it's like I think there's certain part
like when I when I see people that are
ahead of where they are we're like nah I
never do shit like that I'm like you
should like I never want to be the
person who thinks they're better than
they are and I think the better you get
the more you want to go I want to make
sure I'm this good everywhere I like to
like throw myself and do yeah wild shit
as long as it's the stakes are low yeah
because a part of me was like okay well
the next thing I do or whatever like I'm
gonna go work out in in very Hood comedy
rooms whatever where they won't give you
nothing to fuck who you or whatever I
did tell myself that so because you
still want to make sure that you're good
people who only do comedy for their own
fans get real shitty real fast yeah yeah
you get good and then you only perform
for your own fans and you atrophy yeah
so for me it's like the best is like to
like pop in at the store where it's like
Rogan's in town it's his fans or sugar
and birds fans or whatever and then
you're having to like fight a little bit
yeah I don't mind eating it in front of
in front of people who don't know who
the fuck I am or whatever or trying to
because it's really is really all work
until the final product anyway so I was
like all right what did you learn from
that how did you cope with the pandemic
not being able to get on stage I was
cool I just did a bunch of Art and
drawing naked pictures of Whitney
Cummings and shit you know what I'm
saying I did a gang of art how do you
always been an artist yeah yeah like so
I mean since I was a kid like I uh like
in college I got through a lot of shit
obviously I used to make extra design
clothes for people I used to draw like
cartoon characters shit on like pants
and I would sell them to like college
kids and like all that shit for like 75
and I could eat for like three weeks or
whatever like yeah because I would yeah
whoa I was doing that in junior high
where people wanted me to draw like
Pokemons and all that shit or whatever
like all right here it is whatever when
did you know you could draw
um
uh I was probably like
10. and did you practice like it was
Loki it was Loki like natural like where
I was like oh all you have to do is just
draw that thing exactly how that is
that's like some gifted ass like shit
like all you got to do your Ted Talk on
how to be a good artist just draw what
you see yeah yeah
can you draw in a way that but here's
the thing it's like the same thing where
I'm always like how did you find out you
could sing because in order to really
commit to it you have to risk being
vulnerable yep and you have to try and
be willing to fail so it's like the kind
of thing like I will never know if I can
sing because I will never do it for real
because I'm too afraid I'll embarrass
myself yeah you know same with like
drawing is like I'll always half-ass it
just so that like it's my idea that it
sucked yeah what I mean that's another
thing is like you got to be cool with
like like on like on this one right here
like the the um like you that don't
really look like you or whatever but you
can tell it's kind of you but it's also
like a funny interpretation of me right
as well right right so you got to be
cool with but the lines and everything
are good or whatever so you got to be
good so I'm I'm fine yeah that's the one
thing out for sure that I had to get
right I was like this bitch this is
crazy so I'm gonna get them right uh but
like how did you this is such a I mean
I'm obsessed with just like the BR like
how why did you pick the mint green why
did you pick this like it almost looks
like a like a uh it looks like a VHS
tape yeah yeah so I actually I mean
that's actually a a really a real uh a
real porn um a real porn video whoa
whatever so I said so I said oh Cummings
clearly I said Cummings so I said oh
won't you draw as a porn star and you're
missing this and that
oh and I was looking at different colors
and shit I said man what you put that
shit like mint green or some shit so it
takes off the I love mint green you know
so so it's not I could have made that
shit way more sexual than it is but the
mint green is kind of funny yeah there's
just like it makes it sort of more
playful you
know I'm trying to
uh like sexualize this part it makes it
like silly yeah I think you also put
pubes on me what's that Black in between
my fingers oh best Shadow okay you got
pubes I do have pubes you talked about
this well they're back a little but it's
also like I lasered them for so long
they're like Smithers hairs they're not
they don't they're not coming back in
like a thick foresty oh okay consistency
you got that good hair it's kind of like
Theo's mullet oh okay
it's a little it's a it's like a narrow
oh okay like an arrow to the pussy yeah
it's not working oh it's not working but
it's another well that's crazy do you
like dudes who manscape
here's the thing with that
um so well first of all manscape.com
promo code Whitney love that love anyone
that uses manscaped however if you're
gonna shave your pubes the problem is
like some guys they're like I'll do it
once a week but if you've got that
raised if you if it's like like five
o'clock shadow that'll rub on you and
give you like a rash and you think it's
herpes and as you got a herpes scare
it's like you gotta do it if you're
gonna do it great just do it regularly
yeah man because I I every now and then
I do that shit it's sharp and then and
it'd be fine it'd be cool it'd be Bobby
oh nigga I got extra dick you know what
I'm saying but then like but then I'm
certainly not gonna suck your dick if
you're not shaving erratically I don't
need my nose having rug burn but
whenever I grow back you be getting bump
so you'll be like yo should have like a
Dorito or whatever the fuck but anyway
yeah I'm picking up what were you just
picking up oh I don't know all your
motherfucking diet pills
these are vitamins that Dr David
Sinclair who wrote lifespan told me that
I should take Dr Davidson Sinclair I'm
David Sinclair uh uh Ed a man NAD and
Resveratrol oh I bought something for
you Whitney what uh vitamins quote
unquote vitamins a little bit a little
bit really yeah I don't know
what what's going on but I want you to
have a good fucking time when you date
people
okay
DTF when booty calls what this is for
you I got this from the Museum of Sex in
New York wait and I need you to have
that are these going your butthole no
it's not suppository you fucking eat
that motherfucker this is never good
when it's in in bold in the back do not
take if nursing or pregnant are you
nursing or pregnant it's anyone's guess
when booty calls what does it do take
capsule within uh uh one capsule within
12 to 16 ounces of water 45 minutes
prior to sexual activity that you think
I have that much notice do you think I'm
planning what kind of horror do you
think I am oh I don't know like I got
you all fucked up apparently for best
results take one hour apart from other
supplements and or medications effects
are normally activated upon stimulation
yeah how can something be activated upon
stimulation if it's taken orally I think
this goes in your pussy no I think you
just eat it and you know so fucked up
about it is I was about to have you
taken these no so I was about to take
that shit but I was like oh that's for
women so I was like oh shit I said I was
gonna make my pussy wet what like oh
shit but wait why hold on it's got
Jensen
Alex jones.net hell no I got this in
front of me licorice licorice licorice I
can't pronounce any of the shit
percentage okay vitamin B vitamin B6
vitamin B2 vitamin E
what does it do I don't know I think it
let me see this shit like I think it
just makes you healthy so that you got
energy can you can you just put it on
there on the display maybe it's meant to
just be looked at okay
DTF I mean remember the Sky Mall catalog
I feel like they would have said DTF
supplement what that shit supplement
okay my algorithm is now fucked okay
okay introducing women's libido
supplements oh yeah make you hornier all
right we're not ashamed to oh yeah
because in La all the guys are gay so
you need a supplement to make it Jesus
we're not ashamed to say that we wanted
uh key benefits shit what are the
benefits uh by the way I first I just
started using sex toys for the first
time in my life
oh you are only fans I am on only fans
using the sex toys not only not on only
fans oh I don't I I'm not that you
bought it what kind did you get Chelsea
Lynn got me so we got them like as a
joke for the podcast and then
one night I took a NyQuil
and I was like what's this all about
like maybe I'll get a joke out of it or
something and it was not a joke really
it's serious shit if I am I haven't been
on a date since I'm like I need nobody
I'm squirrel in your bed and shit no I
don't I think I don't really squirt I
feel like I'm dehydrated
I feel like I need like some Powerade or
something
I feel like everyone's out there just
peeing themselves I don't know whatever
the fuck it is it's lovely I don't need
to be a squirter dude my mattress Matt
do you know how expensive a mattress is
like I don't I respect
in the course
how do you think I got where I am you
think I'm out there she's got old Spurs
I'm just saying I'll never be able to
squirt on my bed oh okay you know what I
mean because that's a it's just like
it's gonna
it's there's some urine in all squirt
I mean a lot of it's pee who gives a
fuck start peeing on people
that's disrespectful not if none of us
in the moment what are the okay what are
the main like what's your what are the
main
what do you find unattractive the girls
do these days sexually because I feel
like girls are getting like unattractive
aggressive and guys are kind of like ah
I'll hit you but don't tell me to do it
unattractive like I'll choke you but you
begging for me to choke you I don't like
females who choke me in there oh
obviously I just had this I just I
recently had this real heavy-handed
chick scratching me and shit man big
fist bitch I
feel like
I'd like
I show shit
when I was younger I thought that would
be sexy and now I'm like why did you do
that you'd be scraping this shit like
when I was young I think I thought that
that was like he would think that was
hot he was watching a lot of fucking
shit it's not films yeah yeah I don't
know she's heavy-handed how
she was heavy-handed social like so I
know even she heavy-handed or whatever
she would try a scratch and all that
shit or whatever and I'm like ow
fix my skin like
my shit was like scrape the fuck up
it was bad
do you think that that she was doing it
like in a performative way or like for
real
I don't know but it was dumb how were
you like it together or was it just like
a in and out situation it was it was
casual but I mean I know the person but
it was casual yeah are you able to sleep
with someone and keep it casual yeah
really I've never I don't know how to do
that like I've never I like if I am
dating someone we're together for like
three years three years and there's no
and it's just like
you date everybody for three years I
just feel like I've never casually dated
in my life did you go to college I did
date someone named Lance oh my God you
know what I mean that by the name Lance
sound like that baby was a terrorism
this is gonna be casual like I maybe
I've done it a couple times like I did a
football player like I think there was
times I've rebounded literally with
basketball
to try to make the guy before jealous
because I was so immature and I don't
want to do shit like that see man that's
where I be trying to get in now I'll be
trying to be the root the rebound dude
but I'm all is the guy that they love
and then the guy and they Rebound with
another dude but I got rebound
personality you think you're gonna be a
rebound guy with a fucking easel yeah
you're a painter you're a hilarious
painter yeah man who was in an orphanage
you are marriage material but I mean
that's what they think I don't want to
get married you want to get married
I was engaged and I was totally fine to
get married I just kind of was like I
don't know if I want to sign anything in
the state of California like I don't
need to get the government like I'll
have the party I'll do the ring I just
like I've signed so many bad contracts
in my day I just I don't Hollywood
prevented his bitch from True Love hey
dude after you've done enough business
with Warner Brother it's kind of hard to
sign yeah at the dotted line it's just
it's like and it's also it's like going
Downtown it's like we're gonna drive
downtown to the place where when we have
to do it for like a ticket it's a night
like I don't want to have to find
parking like we'll break up looking for
parking getting this marriage
certificate man like I love you but not
enough to go down you sound flaky to
Hill Street I just like I just feel like
like when you get engaged to someone
like it's like yeah it's like things are
going well and then all of a sudden it's
like here's a bunch of chores and
logistical things and paperwork and I'm
like what this was fun like 20 minutes
ago and now it's paperwork I mean yeah I
mean I don't know about marriage I may
have a kid or some shit I don't know the
state of California I don't do business
with Gavin Newsom as a general rule this
thing this is why you'll never be able
to lock down Whitney comments I just
like I'm a Biz I'm like a business
person first and foremost and it just
marriage is the the deal points aren't
there yet yeah all right they're not
there yet and also I want to reserve the
right if we have a kid to like if you
like I'll kill you damn you know what I
mean like I could see that for you I
just have seen like I've talked about
like and I've been on and off with a
therapist and back on recently because
I've been looking into adopting in um
like Appalachian the opioid crisis okay
and uh and I was like I don't know if I
can have kids like I know the person I
become when I get protective or angry
like in Animal Welfare like I have
traveled with
box cutters and hammers in case I find a
hot you know car with a dog in it I like
I'm smashing window I like I know who I
am
that's not a Karen it's Karen is no
that's a Carol Baskin fine fuck it it
starts with a k or a c
i feel like blondes have ruined it for
the rest of us all the Cairns are Blonde
by the way and that's a different kind
of privilege that's the level of white
privilege that none of us even
understand because the thing about
theranos
um I think all those women in Trader
Joe's that wouldn't wear masks blonde
people still be wearing a mask can you
believe that I don't buy dude when you
see someone in a mask you're like
also by the way like I don't for a
second think you're protected like
you're covering a herpes outbreak yeah
you don't like some like the herpes
flared up and that was a convenience one
time I took a Plan B pill and I and I
chased it with some water and it felt
like my dick was hard but it wasn't hard
what's up with that what was your plan a
uh I was just trying to be funny for the
home girl let me take one of these she
was like cool I ain't used the 12th and
whatever so I was like yeah I'm about to
hit this shit that shit was like
expensive yeah what is an implant B
build it's probably just like a lot of
progesterone and estrogen right I don't
know it's like the equivalent of four
birth control pills or something oh well
whatever it was it made it made my dick
not hard but it felt hard have you ever
done one of those like Bluetooth things
or um Roman swipes what's that okay
Bluetooth is like a it's like a it's a
gum or something it's like an edible
it's an edible candy that makes your
dick hard yes I took a Viagra before
though my next door neighbor used to
give them to me
yeah yeah did you what was that what was
their motive what was oh oh because I
asked him I was up there like because no
no because I used to I used to bring you
know like chicks to the crib or whatever
he was like hey papa
I've heard you through the walls he was
disappointing yeah
I've seen the faces on the girls you
bring home you're gonna need one of
these he was like this right here you
chase this with some milk and I said
some milk is a some milk trust me Papa
and I took that shit I didn't chase that
shit with no milk but I feel like guys
still think drinking milk makes you come
more I don't know I'm gonna say you
drink some milk oh I just drank milk
right here Louis CK used to joke about
that about how one of his friends was
like uh I'm I'm hung up with this girl
later and so I need to drink milk so I
can come more
and he was like wait do you just think
the body goes white white yeah go on
like just white white got it same time
what is what is going why don't you
think you want get married
um I don't know I just don't I just
don't see it it does seem a little bit
psycho to do but then again I feel like
one person forever in my life like if
you think of it that way because it's
like when I hear that someone's been
married for eight years I'm like that's
a Triumph like I think the forever thing
marriage was invented when the life
expectancy was 30 years old was a
different amount of time back then
people get on my nerves yeah so
I'll tell you what so maybe I do I just
think that the signing the legal stuff
is where shit gets very dicey yeah and I
don't like all that and then I don't
want to live with someone
no not a chick no you see here's the
thing I mean not like I mean I have had
a roommate if I had my sister but not a
not a not a girlfriend hmm
uh I just again I like I like my space I
like that too yeah I will be with you
forever if I see you twice a week every
day it's just not gonna because I just I
need so much solo time which I actually
think is part of like what I was asking
earlier because I'm still kind of trying
to figure out why I became a comedian
because I'm just like what what am I
like this is this was wild like this is
wild yeah that we come from what we come
from and we are like
managed to Triumph in this way where we
don't have to have regular jobs because
we would never dude I survived two hours
as a bartender I mean I cannot function
in the world unless I'm able to just
kind of um overthink things and make
strangers laugh even if they don't like
me it's the only thing that I can like
do you ever feel like um like a friend
of mine is having a birthday thing in
September and I'm like oh God why do I
have to respond to this right now it's
like you got to reserve your room and
I'm like why not and then I was like you
know what I need to book this because
such a big part of humans being happy is
having something to look forward to
you know I mean even if I don't go on
this and I cancel the week before which
I'm sure I will and like doing stand up
there's something of also like next year
I'm on tour like I'm going to Minnesota
like I have to stay alive I have to stay
healthy like I owe this to the people
about tickets it's like a contract
you're making that's kind of tricking
you into staying healthy and creative
because you owe something yeah yeah like
I had to kind of trick myself into
living in a way that where I didn't just
die yeah yeah it's kind of like how like
I'll be I'll I'll go to New York or
whatever and then I'll just like book in
acting class just to have something to
look forward to or something to do while
I
yeah like I feel like that's something
we like I didn't realize was such a big
part of Sanity of going like someone's
gonna need me in six months yeah I need
to like keep my shit together do this
yeah yeah you know if I do it day by day
I'm just like uh what is this for
because I think that it's like when I
was young the way that I survived was to
look ahead yeah when I was a kid I would
pretend I was on Oprah for real it's so
dark okay I would imagine myself have
you ever been to Opera no no I was
imagining I was in commercials like I
would eat as if I was in commercials
like I would roll up cold cuts and like
eat them like the way I was like
practicing for I just would be like I
was like I'm Gonna Be Live in the
commercials like that I'm gonna eat
like burgers my pillow was my girlfriend
a lot okay that was my type of thing you
know so that was my pretend you know
that was my Oprah I'm not let me cut you
off on this one that was my girl I mean
that was my Oprah as in you would you
I did have a I did when I was in Texas
once seriously think I had a fly that a
friend that was a fly oh man you sound
like Andrew Tate when he was in prison
he was like the rats are my friends they
know poetry you didn't see what Henry
Tate was going through that shit do you
think someone like Andrew Tate is like
like more of a performance artist or do
you think he believes what he's saying
uh I think he believes what he's saying
and that's what makes him a performance
artist interesting uh do you think
someone like that is truly dangerous
no I mean I mean dangerous like he knows
MMA but like yeah
you know like I don't think he's gonna
physically I mean I I don't know I don't
know the dude so I'm like I don't think
that he's gonna hurt you I think the
part I think those people in a way I
think he just wants to be a man
interesting but I think or a comedian I
think a lot of people we see acting out
honestly if they had been comedian like
like Kanye think of
okay so I'm I am we'll defend Kanye
horror me too I love Kanye West that he
so Kanye like you know look and I'm not
gonna get into the neurodivergent
echelons because it changes every day
and there's like it's not my place to
diagnose everybody but Kanye is someone
like he can express himself very clearly
through music very and when it's words
it all falls apart I I identify with
that as a genius musician a one of a
kind um Talent kidding but I can express
myself well through comedy I can express
through writing conversations or kind of
all falls apart I'm either too sarcastic
or I say something that that alienates
people or I kind of go too hard like
it's just very clear that he is
incredibly
um
deaf to communicating through music and
when he's able to write something and I
think that a lot of times someone like
that you're trying to make a joke and
like he can't read a room
sometimes he I mean sometimes in his
interviews he'd be saying some really
deep and poignant shit and we're just
like oh how and it'd be it'd be like
certain shit be like on some spiritual
like and I'm like and everybody like
he's crazy but I'm like nah he's
actually seeing some real motherfucking
if you just like stop being invested in
destroying someone who's famous and Rich
because I think it was when some when
someone's famous and Rich all of a
sudden you have no sympathy for them if
he was like broke and saying that she'd
be like wait a minute let's hear him
that's why we love Nipsey hustle you
know because he also was saying the same
amount of real shit or whatever and we
loved him more because he was in the
hood more so it seemed like he was poor
he wasn't poor nope but it seemed like
he was in the hood more so stayed there
it seemed like he was for the people
Kanye
speaking some real motherfucking shit
but he is
you know fucking Kardashians and shit
like that so we're like man fuck him he
don't know what he's talking about I'm
like he's a genius you know yeah it's
he's he you know and I think that like
our society is on like a like just sort
of a countdown to when we can tear
someone down that we built up you know
it's like for Beyonce's last album when
they were like um she approach took us
and you're like y'all have just been
waiting for this moment haven't you yeah
to just destroy this woman who has done
nothing but provide you fucking bitch up
there dancing her motherfucking asshole
Lawless
and they're like just waiting for
they're waiting for them to fuck up
which I know what that's like I know
that that human nature Kink of when
someone trips up that kind of like yeah
because you're like I must not be a
piece of shit because I you get this
vicarious high from seeing someone like
that's what Jay-Z used to have a line
where he's the uh a rap line where he's
like build me up to break me down to
build me up again they're like Hove we
need you back so we can kill your ass
again but like
you know what I mean so it's like this
it's
it's in Rome we were watching people get
torn apart by tigers like the Roman
Colony that's our that's our nature and
like we've recreated that with the way
that we treat and I think that when
someone's Rich there's no sympathy for
them which I totally understand but like
the fact that what was happening with
Adidas is he was getting paid you know
millions and millions but he was owed
billions and his point was like you owe
me all this but people go oh well you
got hundreds of millions so you know we
can steal friends like no no I deserve
all give me all my shoes yeah and white
people they get the billions they're
owed and as soon as I got 800 million
and I'm owed 2 billion you're like oh
he's had enough so he came off like a
greedy asshole or something you know and
then him aligning with Trump was like
look I I think that that it's the I just
go okay remember I'm not going to name
any names but when you look at you know
Whitney Houston and all these like great
artists and Prince and all these great
artists that we lost you're kind of like
how fucking sad was it that it just but
that they
I'm trying to really choose my words
there was no one around them you know
that was just like hey bud let's just
like let's just like go to the Bahamas
for a month let's just go chill like
let's just like protecting him it seems
like there's no one around him I used to
always say about I mean I used to always
say about Kanye where I was like man you
know what's so crazy it's like yeah you
know you know I know his mom and all
that stuff like all that stuff whatever
and I said but you don't ever hear about
Kanye's like cousins or something who
would be like yo man you know what I'm
saying like come stay with me for like
you'll never hear about any other family
remember somebody to keep them saying
remember we're like I mean if you if you
let us if you let the public think about
it we only think you got you know your
kids uh uh Kim and that's it because
your mom's you know we don't know who
your dad is or whatever we'll never hear
about Kanye dad you never hear about his
cousins or does he have brothers or any
of that shit
he's getting the PayPal requests yeah
yes they come out of the woodwork you
know but hey I don't have you seen the
Netflix documentary on Kanye yeah I saw
a little bit it was kind of sad so I
stopped watching it gets even more
Harper and you're and also when you see
him at 18 doing that you're like
you I already am like this is the way
his brain works is so on another level
you're like it has to lack in Social the
ability to read social cues the ability
to like there's something else
the brain is his brain is so unique and
um gifted
and if you've been doing that for that
long you probably lack socialization
regardless even if it's not something
that's neurological or genetic yeah you
know but I think a lot of people like
when I look at
it's gonna be a hot take but when I look
at the stuff that he says a lot of the
time it's like I feel like he was trying
to be funny like a lot of people are
trying to be a lot of people that trash
us on social media they're like fuck you
they're trying to be funny and it just
like doesn't land I hate I mean no I
love social media but I hate it because
you can't hear you can't hear tone
you know like I'll Tweet shit or
whatever and I'm like no I'm like if you
if you just thought about it in my voice
whatever like you know that's the thing
about tweeting too it's like there needs
to be a voice Twitter you know like
what's there what I know I said there
needs to be a voice well I just think in
general Comics have to just just go oh
right we do our thing at 8pm in person
we don't do it during the day
written oh yeah but also it's like
comedians or people who like we thought
we were I mean we think that we're funny
I mean we thought we're funny we're kids
and we think that we're funny around our
Social Circle or whatever so we're we're
always like trying to be funny or
whatever like that's that's the only
thing we want from that shit you know
I'm saying so like when we do comedy or
whatever when we say shit on social
media which is trying to be funny or
whatever for the most part I ain't gonna
say all the time but I think Comics like
like I think Comics can be kind of
bratty of like wanting their cake and
having to eat it too and I think most
Comics the whole thing is like they're
able to like see reality as it is it's
like okay if you're writing some a great
abortion joke on Twitter right and two
in the afternoon on Tuesday you can't
control number one how it's read the
intonation the reading it in the whole
point where people come pay us is
they're not only paying us for the joke
we wrote but we're delivering it in a
way where you can hear something Shady
with a smile and like you know so you
don't have the delivery which is half of
what we do and then you can't control
what it's it's in between right so it's
like your Tweet could be going in
between Trump is running again and 12
kids shot at a school yeah and then or
it's retweeted and someone that doesn't
follow you that has not signed up for
comedians jokes gets that shit on their
desk at two in the afternoon and
someone's like what the fuck so it's
like I wouldn't run up to some stranger
and be like here's my abortion joke at
two in the afternoon they have to filter
your joke through their current emotions
that you know what I'm saying so like
there's the other day I posted I don't
know if even even if you saw that shit
but I was like on um I was on Bumble or
whatever
I was trying to fight like almost thing
now is that you the woman has to
initiate that's why you're getting these
women with big ass hands
they want to initiate the date the thing
about the thing about the thing about
the dating apps right now is like okay
well there's a lot of um you know much
respect anybody who chooses to be
whatever the fuck they want to be but
like you know I like transgender people
on there right and they always and and
so I put because I just want wait a
minute that's all I want women so so I
put I put hey you did you die remember
that I put hey can I put can hey can
trans people stay on their side of the
dating app like right and I put that and
then I posted my uh
I posted my profile on Instagram right
and then people were like well how would
you like it if if women were if someone
was like can black people stay on their
side today that's not the same thing
exactly and that's what I said it's not
the same thing I can't articulate why
right this second but that is nothing
yeah and I said hey and I said no no I
said it's just a preference I say it's
like when women put on their profiles
like hey I don't like dudes on a five
nine I don't like dudes with kids and I
like dudes who smoke and then she was
like women over 5 12. yeah I don't like
women over six four and then she was
like well you should have said it like
that the way you said it and I said I
didn't say it I just wrote it bitch you
just reading it in an aggressive way you
know you should have said it like that
you should have had better shit to do
than just fight me like why are people
allowed to have the craziest Kinks like
you're allowed to be like I Only Wanna
Fuck with a knife against my neck in a
in a furry outfit but if you say I don't
want to sleep with a trans woman like
you're an asshole right you know people
got preferences did I had to check who
wanted to write fantasy before yeah if
it's not rape if it's a plan
not of us pretend so what did you did
you did
do it you know yeah I did it of course I
did it so what did you what did you do
you staged a fake audition a fake
Hollywood audition you know I did so the
girls had uh so the girl said hey I'm
gonna leave my door opening yo you is
going to come in that's not rapists
don't they don't open a door that's been
open this already isn't a rape whatever
man just let us play
like I don't want to know when you're
gonna come
so I said so neither of you are employed
at this point no no no no not at all
it's just all lit all fun like
okay everybody end part one
of this podcast we ain't talking about
shit brought to you by Bailey's and
bearing younger honey liquor and rotten
Luther King Jr don't ride elephants
[Music]
thank you